foreign
[Music]
he's like an amazing Storyteller and
then didn't they like death threat his
ass to say oh you want a [ __ ] retired
[ __ ] we're gonna kill you so
then he goes oh I guess I have to work
for another game Metal Gear we're
talking about Konami Konami is [ __ ]
with them they were [ __ ] no no no
fans fans sent him a debt they're like
you have to [ __ ] finish because
remember you wouldn't finish [ __ ]
like metal gear or some [ __ ] like that
no he got kicked out of Konami and then
Konami holds the rights for Metal Gear
he has his own production company they
were telling they're telling him you
better [ __ ] finish this [ __ ]
[ __ ] he goes no I'm gonna retire
I'm too old okay retired [ __ ]
I'm gonna kill you especially for a
Japanese guy those guys just run until
they die that's true they work till
they're 98 and then they die at 103.
Miyazaki has been retired like 10 times
now and he keeps on coming back and be
like Oh my son's [ __ ] it up didn't
she get her my Moto like not even retire
yet like the Mario creator I don't know
actually he's a psychopath he did Mario
he did [ __ ] zeldas he did [ __ ]
smash bass
he did Bitcoin as well yeah just got
killed uh so so hideo Kojima has
threatened legal action against people
who are falsely linking His image with
the guy who just assassinated Japanese
prime minister yeah that's fair that
sucks I don't even know what he like
really looks like yeah what do you know
could you looks like no like no I don't
know a murderer how about that today
yeah like no I don't know what he looks
like he just looks like an oh I don't
know I don't know all those guys look so
[ __ ] basic to me that they all blur I
don't even know you guys are talking
about it looks like a Japanese
businessman well you should know um
Metal Gear Metal Gear sick which one's
Metal Gear is it the one where you're
running the guy with a snake he's a
secret agent do you jump in a
metal slug oh
that looks more like the killer that
yeah yeah he looks like this now though
Loki that just looks like a regular
Japanese that's what I'm saying he looks
so basic look at this joke stylish
that's like my [ __ ] cousin right
there so yeah hideo Kojima I got like 10
cousins that look like him
oh thank you is that right hey Dale I
don't know you I mean tell me is it Jack
Nicholas
I don't understand the reference what
are you talking about
what's off camera huh it's padeo
point is he's a legend he everyone's you
know there was some people online who
were saying that the Assassin looks like
him and uh it looks like he's basically
just pushing back saying like yo that's
not to me don't say that [ __ ] I will
[ __ ] sue your ass I will kill you
with a handmade gun yeah
yeah what a funny thing to be like
so there was a politician
um from French uh uh fall politics
Prince Paul French politics thank you
um his name is Damien Ryu and he
retweeted images of hideo Kojima with
the comment the extreme left kills
so yeah that's wild why you just accuse
anybody now what a weird oh [ __ ] you
could just say stuff politicians tweet
some crazy [ __ ] sometimes the news is
[ __ ] wild too I was just on I was on
Fox news earlier looking at um at
articles and [ __ ] right and there was a
there was like it's like guy gets
murdered in democrat-run city I'm like
all cities are Democrat run basically
people are wild right now you gotta put
your little politics in every guy no one
dies in Republican cities now they go
that's exactly it that's giraffe dies in
Republican Zoo
cynical
okay we got it through your through your
your life people are wilding out
um so yeah so you know the politician
then deleted the Tweet because obviously
he told the same person he's wrong and
uh did he say hey sorry I just thought
it would look like a nutshank she says I
naively took a joke for information I
didn't think we could make humor about
the assassination of a man but I was
wrong not to check before sharing my
apologies to hideo Kojima and to the
fans of metal gear which is pretty funny
thing to say yeah
dude that's when you know he [ __ ] up a
very specific group of people don't [ __ ]
with male gear fans that's that's some
uh that's some [ __ ] defamation
lawsuit [ __ ] you have to go down you
know what I mean you guys ever play
[ __ ] what's metal can you show me
metal gears yeah dude I've been talking
about Metal Gear for a long time it's my
favorite game ever it's probably like
one of the best first games that you
play in Nintendo like as a child right
so there's Super Mario and well no
there's regular Mario and then you play
like [ __ ] duck hunt but then Metal
Gear changed the game like when you
[ __ ] play that you're just like what
the [ __ ] but then it gets crazier and
crazier like yeah it gets a little too
wild
foreign
but didn't it start with Nintendo when
it was that shitty ass it was before
Metal Gear Solid because solid is when
it came to the place metal gear and then
those Metal Gear 2 revenge of snake or
whatever and then there's this one which
was like the one that exploded
um but the stories got better though
yeah yeah story got great but the cool
thing about it like so what he did
originally on Nintendo and frankly I
only know about this because I was
obsessed with this game and I found out
about those games right but so there was
like a game where you could do stealth
right like you're in the military and
you're doing stealth and so like the
game can actually see if you're if it
spots you or not and so the bad guys
will notice you unless you're sneaking
around the right way so that was what
was so [ __ ] cool about Metal Gear it
was like revolutionary at the time
um Anthony you're pulling up some
footage I'm trying to like show a little
bit of gameplay of Metal Gear Solid from
the PlayStation oh yeah are you doing
right anime
but like you know when I was kind of a
legend in this game a little bit you
know what I mean in my own home
Counter-Strike before Counter-Strike huh
no no no no because no no no this was
it's a different thing that's not first
person you're in AIM mode but then third
person story based but like it's like
more like GTA we have a character that
you control yeah yeah but you know and
it was you know how do you Kojima kind
of references that he was inspired by um
Snake Plissken from the Escape movies so
I could Escape From New York with Kurt
Russell yeah yeah yeah cause like that's
a that's a movie about like a president
has his daughter kidnapped and then like
are you a bad enough dude to go rescue
her is basically the meme of it right
yeah they both have eye patches so then
they get this guy who's like whose name
is snake in the movie
um to like it's like you know snake we
need your help and he's like I'm retired
dude that's where it really started and
then he's like I'll never [ __ ] work
you [ __ ] again and they're like I
required a set of skills we put a bomb
in your head and we're gonna [ __ ]
blow it up unless you do this [ __ ] and
then he's like such a [ __ ] got me
again he's like can I smoke or is it
gonna [ __ ] with bomb like you can smoke
uh cool yeah
so smoking is cool all that's really
cool Grizzle talk is cool right A Good
Old Marlboro sponsorship day that's
really what made those movies cool
though cigarettes so much yeah yeah and
so then hey grandson audio Kojima kind
of does like a almost like a homage to
that with metal gear one so his name is
snake same [ __ ] like he like same story
mechanics and like you know um there was
a facility on Shadow Moses Island got
[ __ ] taken over by bad guys like they
got nukes what are you gonna do and so
he's like I'm [ __ ] retired bruh
we still got a bomb in your head yeah
yeah we didn't have to do that but they
did do something with him where like
they injected him with something and uh
that plays a big part in the team
that wasn't Metal Gear Solid but Fox die
and Metal Gear Solid and then the new
James Bond movie actually ripped it off
Big Time wow and no time to die yeah
they did they did Big Time yeah I think
about that with the blood yeah okay yeah
it's fascinating yeah so anyway Mega
solid Legendary game got Wilder in the
second game right the second game I
don't even know what the [ __ ] was going
on naked right and they were wilding out
they were wilding out big time dude
halfway through they changed snake out
so you're not even snake anymore and now
you're just a [ __ ] blonde-haired
anime character [ __ ] ninja but he
wasn't great he was a little [ __ ] boy
naked for half the game yeah and he was
like whining and crying into the [ __ ]
Kodak the whole time you know you're
selling three was cool though never saw
threesome then you're in Vietnam and you
had to like eat snakes and [ __ ] exactly
the Snake Eater snake eating snake yep
and his titties bouncing all over the
[ __ ] place actually any game that had
titties bouncing out was like remember
dead or alive
no yeah yeah they're a live extreme
beach volleyball dude I don't even think
I ever threw a punch in that game I was
having [ __ ] jump up and down the
whole [ __ ] time or even with Street
Fighter where that totally goes upside
down and you're hoping that her panties
show you're like yeah yeah dude dude
Chun Lee get those legs up in the air
yeah or what's their name and kill her
Instinct at the end where she [ __ ]
just
oh but the backside you know what I'm
talking about yes
Orchid wait and there was a Mortal
Kombat like like like maleena was doing
some titty [ __ ] like some finish him but
then I finished herself um
brilliant brilliant gameplay cities are
so awesome man
what game did you play bar uh I played
Barclay I run from the Jazz cleaner
I played duck hunt I thought that was
fun
um we didn't have uh what is it called
Nintendo we had one of those Chinese
Nintendo ones so they're kind of cool
because like you get a cartridge there's
like 500 like off-brand games you don't
really know what they are but they're
kind of like you're like oh this one's
kind of like it's like goose hunt yeah
yeah you're like this one's kind of like
Super Mario donkey Kang yeah is that a
Mario it's like it's like it's Pierre
it's like a French character that's
walking around did you ever have those
tiger things Bart where like remember
little tiger handheld devices the little
like black and white characters would
kind of move around and add some of
those yeah little LCD games there was
like one game yeah yeah almost one game
yeah it's like it's like a one game and
you would play it and then the it would
give you levels and it would just make
it faster so it would just be like until
you couldn't do it anymore but yeah that
so you played like all the off-brandship
that and then but when I went to my
friend's house that had Sega then like
Shinobi that was really cool and then uh
you should know it's a Super Nintendo
then like uh Mario Kart that was pretty
fun you guys missed like game like do
you guys still play yeah well I haven't
in a while I'm no gamer by any means but
what's the last game you played uh I'm
I'm in the middle of playing God of War
4 for the second time because God of War
4 Ragnarok comes out this November damn
those things
yeah holy [ __ ] yeah so God of War 4 is
what I said God of War four God War four
is what I was talking about I had a
friend that had that and there was like
the [ __ ] coolest kid this is the
[ __ ] cool I remember like you know
how some of those days it'd be like oh
rainy day day and then the kids that had
that then during recess because you
can't go outside to play they bust those
out you're like oh my God I [ __ ] hell
we hated those kids they were killing or
the kids with the game boys yeah and all
I could look at was Big Five coupons yo
man game boys are much bigger than I
remembered oh the original one there
yeah and then if you had the light [ __ ]
on the speaker [ __ ] on it you're a
[ __ ] loser bro dude I love the
[ __ ] like warm light that they had
because it never showed because it would
just be like Overland see just be like
what the [ __ ] am I looking oh you ever
see the boys cases for their game boys
yeah that was me what was that the
[ __ ] happened literally
pelican cases and pull out everything
their batteries or cartridges multiple
games and stuff those idiots protecting
their investment I bet you wish you did
that at some point in your life once at
least recently
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]